i'm thinking about your whole brokeback
mountain thing with heath ledger what an
actor this guy was did you get close to
him afterwards like or do you do
brokeback mountain and say you know yeah
if i saw him i'll say hello but do you
actually become good friends after a
movie like that yeah i mean there are a
lot of times where your friends and then
your friends in a space and time and
you're carrying that kind of like the
residual space of the work you did and
the space and the life you had because
it is your life and um
yeah i mean with heath uh
we we were friends from before that
and then uh through it you know it like
fortified
all of us somehow in a way that was just
a crazy experience that was unlikely for
all of us do you think that movie now
could be made with two straight actors
or would it be
under fire would it be oh jake
gyllenhaal's playing a game man this
part should have gone to a gay guy
probably the answer is no
um but but then when i look at it now
as a way in which it paved an
opportunity in a in a time when there
was no real chance that
two you know first of all the two
straight actors were going to play roles
like that openly like and say okay we're
gonna i mean the amount of flack we got
for that i was just like it's crazy i
mean
for a year i mean like for a year after
that it was like
the amount of conversations about what
what my sexuality was was just it was
like i was like all right guys like
and girls i was like guys and girls
everybody
just
chill out like did anybody say to you
listen jake don't play a gay guy early
on there were people going
what are you what are you doing
but i mean i just didn't have i was like
what am i doing this is the most
beautiful story i've ever read i was
literally i was like with ang lee i mean
with ang lee like right he's one of the
best one of the greatest directors yeah
right yeah yeah i mean like they were
stupid frankly like outside of it being
a you know something that people may
have
you know
a type of role of sexuality that people
i was just like i grew up too with like
my godparent my god fathers were like a
gay couple like i you know i i think
maybe i grew up in a space where i took
that for granted and um
that was just that was just no i no one
there wasn't any of that if anything for
me it was like
what is everybody
saying like what is this about like
you know i didn't get the full response
people were joking about it people were
people were offended by there were all
these crazy responses and i realized the
power of moviemaking
that's what i realized
it has a power